so you've been plugged into a bunch of
uh folks who were senior in the
Republican Party 2016 you think okay
guys this is not the way and then a
bunch of them sure are going to be like
I guess this is the way though I'm sure
a few few of them surreptitiously said
to you like oh I don't I don't like
what's going on uh like where where do
you think that group is now
um because I because I'm sure you talk
to people of of uh different backgrounds
and uh you've been talking to them about
structural reform for the last several
years yeah uh yeah because one of the
things that you'd said to me at some
point was like look I'm not sure if
people were ready uh you know four or
five years ago but they're increasingly
ready now I I stand by that in fact I
met with
um some of our wonderful Legacy leaders
from Sam you know I sat down with them
in the spring of 2017 and I said look
I'm nervous we're all nervous we don't
know what we're in for here
um but I think that the predominant
positioning amongst center-right
Republicans is going to be to wait and
see
um you know let's not upset the apple
cart
um you know we still have
Mitch McConnell who we can trust we have
Paul Ryan who we can trust so let's not
upset the apple cart let's keep going
and I don't think that folks are ready
at that time
um I do think this is different I think
it's much different right now and
um we it's just not getting better right
I can't say it is really right it's just
not getting better and I you know
um I am uh I'm an I'm an optimist but
I'm also a pragmatist and you know
there's a colleague of ours in the space
who she and I were on a panel together
last summer and she kept saying that you
know bye talking about fixing the system
the notion of fixing the system and
introducing two-party a new party uh
Were Somehow undermining the system as a
whole and instead what we need to be
doing is reinforcing confidence in the
system and building out moderate factors
said
I'm trying to do that uh for years and
now they're throwing in the towel I mean
I've had a lot of those conversations
heck the entire renew America movement
crew was like we're gonna restore the
Republican party and then they join the
merger because they said you know what
like the Republican party is lost yeah I
just I don't think that it's an option
anymore Andrew I think it's just way too
far gone people have figured out that
they can vent like their negative
impulses and control the party in a
particular way and it's very hard to put
that Genie back in the bottle you know
like they've learned that lesson
well and it's one thing too I think for
folks who
um have visions of of building out
moderate factions within the existing
party structures have never been to a
State Central Committee meeting they
have never been at a platform committee
meeting you know these aren't center
right center left leaders the the
leadership of of the party structures
are the extremes themselves and they are
going to continue to drive uh party
regulations and party rulings in a way
that incentivizes uh extremism so you
know I don't I think that folks who
think of themselves as you know a
center-left you know democrat or
center-right republican
um would be shocked to hear some of the
rhetoric that is coming out of
rulemaking committees in the current
two-party system they are not
representative of of the broad base of
Americans and where we want to go
they're incredibly divisive and um and
not and and they the bomb throwing and
the name calling
um of you know quote the other right
yeah yeah
this process of the humanization yeah I
I I have no I I have no place there and
it is fun how people have come to
forward from different angles uh where
like Matt and Kate you know are former
Dems I don't know if Matt was ever a Dem
that's been third party for a long time
is Andrew you know he and I've had
enough policy conversations to know that
I know where he falls on a lot of things
it's great yeah yeah I was like but at
this point
um we're getting pitted against each
other in this like increasingly uh
destructive and and futile manufactured
conflict uh and so whatever goals we
might have for our country like we have
to say like look like this current
system is not going to serve them like
we have to no we have to upgrade uh and
modernize the the system so you've been
working at forward for a couple months
and by the way you did a bunch of things
that
um I I thought were awesome leadership
where you organized a retreat brought
everyone together like you know like got
like got everyone on the same page you
did a bunch of things I was like oh I
got that's some Aces leadership it's the
kind of thing that that I I would have I
just wanted I just wanted to go to John
Kingston's Farm
I just I just wanted to see Snowy
snow-capped Mountains in Vermont no it
was um so important like culture I know
this is this is you know everyone said
but like culture eat strategy for
breakfast like it does all day long I
mean we can have the great greatest
strategic vision for party building and
if culturally we're all not synced and
there isn't you know a foundation of
trust amongst our team we'll never get
there
foreign